Airbnb might be banned in the UK is that
correct I put up a few posts earlier
talking about the consultation that's
going on within the government about
short stay Lex Airbnb becoming a little
bit more regulated potentially in the
future and as a result a lot of people
are now a little bit worried what do you
mean Samuel that it's going to
potentially be regulated listen this is
not a big deal this is something that
I've predicted back in 2020 I said that
they were going to regulate Airbnb in
short stay that's some service
accommodation and now they are finally
talking a little bit about it so what's
happening what's happening is the hotels
and Villages of small towns Seaside
towns particularly are getting fed up
with their next door neighbors being
rented out on short stay let's and
they're complaining and the government
have said look we'll look into it and
they're Consulting where the potentially
there needs to be some sort of
Regulation within short stay let's
within Airbnb I personally don't think
much is going to change certainly for a
very long time just because it's in
consultation with the government that
does not mean that there's going to be a
new law that comes in loads of stuff all
the time go into consultation by the
government and nothing changes nothing
happens and even if it is a new Lord
does come in it will probably take
months and months maybe even years
before it happens because it has to go
through the House of Commons the House
of Lords Edinburgh announced that they
were going to follow London because
London there is a 90-day rule you can't
rent your property out in London without
planning permission if you're going to
do it for more than 90 days a year and
Edinburgh said right we're going to
follow suit and they said in in a year
and a half's time April 2023 we're going
to bring in that same law and when it
came to it they actually didn't bring it
in and now they're saying or maybe it's
going to be in six months or so there's
no point worrying about something that's
not in yet but it is important to be
forewarned so what's my prediction and
what's going to happen well my
prediction is that at some point I do
think that Airbnb and short stay let's
are going to get more regulated because
at the moment they're pretty much
completely unregulated you can rent out
your shed in your garden on Airbnb no
tenant rights No guest rights no washing
facilities you can just stick it on
Airbnb and rent it out so I do think
that there's going to be some regulation
particularly as the factors that we've
got a massive shortage of houses and
there's a massive shortage of rentals
and the more and more people are renting
out on short stay let's it means that
there's even less of a demand so I do
think they're going to bring in some
regulation and I predict it's going to
be a little bit like Article 4 was for
hmos and I remember back in 2016 when it
was announced that Wolverhampton was
going to become article 4. so if you
want to rent a property out as a HMO you
need planning permission and everybody
was all upset around my neighboring area
of Wolverhampton and they were saying oh
no and they were scared and they weren't
getting into hmos because they knew
about the regulations but I was just
thinking I'm just going to make hayball
the sun shines if I buy a property and
rent it out room by room I'll make a
grand amount of profit if the rule
changes in a year's time and I'm still
made 12 Grand per house like I don't
care if the rule changes I'll cross that
bridge so I really pushed into buying
hmos and then when they brought in
article 4 in Wolverhampton the rules
changed but I had grandfather right
so they said you can't buy properties
and rent them out as hmos unless you've
already been doing it then you have
grandfather rights so it might be that
there's serviced accommodation
grandfather rights
who knows and then all the people that
are scared and are worried you know so
you need to be forewarned I wouldn't
suggest that you go crazy in one
particular town and have a hundred
service accommodation properties whereby
there's no exit strategy you wouldn't be
able to make money on them as singlets
because it's possible that they'll
regulate the area and you'll be really
screwed so diversify you know have
multiple baskets have all your eggs in
one basket but at the same time you've
got to make hay while the sun shines and
at the moment service accommodation is
very unregulated you can rent a property
out on Airbnb on booking.com for a
hundred pound a night make three grand a
month whereas if you rent it out to a
family you might make 800 pound a month
so it's Madness so learn the strategy do
it but be forewarned I think that this
is extremely unlikely I just can't see
that they're going to suddenly put a
blanket ban across the whole of England
because this for a start it's a good
service I use Airbnb all the time I go
and stay in properties there's a lot of
parts of the world whereby there's very
rich people renting their properties out
on Short Stay left I just can't see
they're just going to ban it what they
may do is regulate it and I predict that
they'll probably do it they'll start in
some of the hot spot areas maybe some of
the tourist beaches where the the
communities the local communities are
really moaning and going mad and they go
okay in this area you need a particular
type of planning permission or a license
to do it and then they might start
rolling it out slowly across different
areas it may happen we must be
forewarned but at the same time in the
last two months I've taken on over 60
service department units myself so I'm
aggressively doing it but I'm also doing
biofirmish refinance I'm also doing hmos
I'm also doing purchase for these option
agreements I'm also buying land and
developing houses so it's a string to my
bow it's not the whole guitar that's my
thoughts what are your thoughts let me
know in the comments and I will keep you
updated once the consultation is
finished and we've heard any news or
updates on any regulation of course
we'll keep you updated so make sure you
are subscribed to the YouTube channel
where you always have first on the
Samuel Lee's Channel see you next time
foreign
[Music]